I thought I would make a quick
video to clarify some points
on evolution and maybe clear up
some points of ambiguity in
some of my previous videos.
So when you go to the natural
history museum and you see
these drawings where they start
with a primitive ape and
they show progressive species
that show some form of
progress, at least some form of
progress when it comes to
walking on two feet, it
culminates with Homo Sapiens--
us-- you imagine that evolution
is kind of this
process that creates better
and better things.
You imagine that there's this
notion of progress that, as
time goes on, each successive
species is better than its
first.
And I want to be very clear
that this notion of better
really makes no sense in an
evolutionary or natural
selection context.
That all that matters is fitness
to your environment or
the frequency with which you're
able to reproduce in an
environment, which doesn't
really match to
our notion of better.
So some people kind of think of,
well, what's going to be
the next step in human
evolution?
And they imagine some human with
a big brain that can move
things with mental energy and
all of that and can see
through things or
whatever else.
They imagine some kind of
progress, that, look, we're
more intelligent.
We can do all of these things
that an ape couldn't do.
Maybe the next stage in
evolution somehow will be some
type of superhuman.
And I don't know what the next
stage of evolution, if there
is any next stage for-- I can't
go into that debate, but
the idea is that that's not
necessarily the case.
Even if you take our current
human population, success in
evolutionary terms is very
different than success in our
kind of societal definition.
For example, let's say that
you have two people.
You know, this guy, some dude
here, he's got a Ph.D, he's
got an MD, he's got a lot of
money, I mean, just everything
that society says is a success,
but because he did
his MD, Ph.D, he's been in
school a long time, and he
decides not to have children,
or if he wants to be very
responsible, he looks at how
many people there are in the
world and the overcrowding and
the environmental impact.
So let's say him and his wife,
who is also an MD, Ph.D, and
has all this money and degrees
and have spent a lot of their
time in school, they decide
to have one child.
Let me see, this is his wife,
who has kind of similarly--
she's similarly educated, and
from our point of view is a
very successful, very
responsible couple.
Now let's say that there's some
other guy over here, and
he's just kind of-- for the
sake of it, let's say he's
just nuts, that from the
get-go he was very
irresponsible.
He produced one child
after another.
Let's say by the time he's 30
years old, he has 10 children,
all with different mothers,
maybe some of the children had
to go up for adoption.
Who knows the situation
with this guy's life?
I don't want to be judgmental of
it, but the general idea is
that in society, we would say,
oh, this guy is less
successful.
But from an evolutionary point
of view, this guy was far more
successful.
In fact, people like this guy,
the frequency of their genes
is increasing much faster than
the frequency of these
people's genes.
So when we talk about fitness
from an evolutionary point of
view, it's not necessarily
fitness from the point of view
that we like to think of it in
our regular kind of value
system that we have
in society.
These people looked very fit,
intellectually and, who knows,
maybe physically as well, but
they weren't reproducing.
Their genes aren't being passed
on with the frequency
of these guys.
I forgot the statistic, but
there's something like 80% of
people in Asia have genes from
either one man or some small
collection of men who date--
actually, I think it's from
one man-- from the 1200s.
And it's either probably one
of the Mongol warriors,
whether it's Genghis or Kublai
Khan, but it just shows you
that there are some very-- and
I'm not going to make any
judgments here, but you could
have very kind of aggressive
people who may have raped and
pillaged whole societies, and
they were very successful from
an evolutionary point of view,
even though we might think
that their actions are
despicable.
So I want to give you the
sense that there's not
necessarily the sense
of progress.
If this pattern I described
keeps happening, then this
type of person will become less
and less frequent in the
gene pool and this person will
become more and more frequent
in the gene pool.
So we might end up with
eventually a more aggressive
human population or a less
quote-unquote responsible one.
So I want to make that one
clarification that evolution,
or natural selection, is not
just a series of progressive
steps where we'll slowly and
slowly become-- or any
organism becomes kind of a
better and more intelligent
and faster animal.
It just depends on its
environment and what it's
being selected for.
Now the other thing I want to
clarify is, really, some of
the points I made on the video
regarding intelligent design.
In that video, my intention
was not to really make a
comparison between intelligent
design and evolution.
So you have evolution on this
side and you have intelligent
design on this side.
And I want to be clear, and I
didn't maybe make it clear
enough in that video,
that this debate is
an artificial one.
Evolution really is the basis
of modern biology.
If you want to understand how
the flu works, or if you
wanted to understand the human
genome, or if you wanted to
understand heredity, evolution
is the cornerstone of that.
And it's not complete.
Every day, every year, we're
discovering more and more
about how the process of natural
selection works.
There are still open debates.
People aren't sure the pace at
which evolution occurs, other
factors that might make it occur
faster or slower, but I
want to be clear.
This does explain all
of our observations.
Or let me put it this way: All
of our observations in modern
science are backing up
evolution and natural selection.
And if anything, it is the
basis of modern biology.
So if one were to deny natural
selection and evolution,
they're really denying our
understanding of modern biology.
Intelligent design is a belief
system, and my whole point
behind making that is to try to
maybe reconcile the parties
that favor this with the idea
of evolution, so that they
could reconcile one's religious
beliefs while not
having to deny what is the
cornerstone of modern biology.
And when I talk about design,
I make the point that, look,
you know, rather than looking
at the particular design,
whether it's the eye or a
particular organism, and I
even make the point that there
is no particular design.
Even if you were to point to the
human eye, there's not one
version of the human eye.
There's an infinite variation in
the human eye, so it would
even have to be intelligent
designs,
not intelligent design.
But my whole point behind the
video was to say if you are
inclined to believe in a
designer, then the more
elegant design is at
the system level,
which really is evolution.
Now, I wasn't trying to say
there is a designer or there
isn't a designer.
I was just saying if you are
inclined to believe in one,
this is more profound and gives
more justice to the
designer that you are inclined
to believe in.
This is not science at all.
Intelligent design is a denial
of what all of modern science
is telling us today.
And it's not a theory, as some
proponents of it put it, and
they kind of surround it with
scientific-sounding terms, but
it's not a theory.
You cannot test intelligent
design.
There's no data point that will
confirm or deny whether
somehow something was
designed by some
type of sentient creator.
This is just a belief
system that is
essentially rejecting this.
But I don't want to be
disrespectful of those who
believe in this belief system,
because it comes out of
closely held beliefs.
My goal really is to
reconcile that.
And if you do want to give your
belief in a creator due
credit, you're better looking
at the system
rather than the design.
So I just wanted to make
those two points, two
clarifications.
One on the evolution/intelligent
design--
quote-unquote-- debate.
But it's not really a debate.
This is kind of the cornerstone
of modern biology.
This is something that
just rejects that.
It isn't a provable or
disprovable theory.
And I wanted to make the point
that evolution doesn't
necessarily mean a
straightforward line of
progress in evermore
intelligent
and impressive creatures.